benjamin castaldi mon benji vous vous
m'avez dit vous avez dit aux équipes moi
ce soir
j'aimerais demander pardon à quelqu'un
ben en fait deux
on peut pas passer n'est pas d'accord
les cépages armes à feu passé et mais
pour l'instant il ému on va pas eric
naulleau
oui oui un épisode dont je garde un
mauvais souvenir du temps où il
officiait on n'est pas couché c'est
qu'on recevait harry roselmack qui avait
fait un roman on l'avait quand même bien
bien massacrés et il l'a très mal pris
et c'est la seule fois où je suis allé
voir quelqu'un en coulisse parce qu'il
était tellement affecté par les
critiques je crois même qu'ils avaient
les larmes aux yeux et moi quand je
critique un bouquin c'est pas pour faire
de la peine à l'auteur chef fort mon
métier honnêtement mais là j'ai vu que
ça dépassait le cadre professionnel ça
devait personnel et ça m'a toujours
restée en mémoire et je regrette cet
épisode donc je voudrais dire à harry
roselmack que ça n'avait rien de
persévérer en 2006 mais il est venu
représenter son roman nos vies lui dont
on n'est pas couché sur france 2 les
séries que vous l'aviez pas épargné
regardez on a retrouvé cette séquence et
il paraît qu'il ya c'est vrai qu'à paris
après un été où l on est allé voir en
coulisses
tellement ils avaient l'air affecté et
un regard des airs et pourquoi tout le
monde veut faire un roman et
particulièrement les journalistes on
voit c'est que je ne vous avais pas
assez travaillé il ya beaucoup de
phrases qui ne sont pas possibles qui
n'aurait jamais dû être dans votre livre
tellement de shamballa 3 c est ce que
sous cette question générale il ya
l'idée que ce livre n'est pas assez
écrit et qu'il faudra le reprendre ses
salines exactement il faut tout
reprendre je pense non moi ce qui
m'étonne c'est que vous passiez d'un
niveau de professionnalisme
incroyable un amateurisme totalement
voilà donc âpre et serrée car ils
étaient très affectés dont vous voulez
lui demander c'est votre pardon de ce
soir bah oui je joue et qui comprenne
bien que c'était vraiment pas contre lui
c'était un jugement sur le sur le lit et
je suis vraiment désolé de l'avoir
blessée à titre personnel voilà donc un
agent que si un mec que j'adore harry en
plus les salles à petit c'est un super
mec et qui quand il fait un truc voilà
il le fait vraiment le coeur je trouve
qu'il essaie vraiment de bien le faire
donc on t'embrasse harry jean michel
maire alors moi on va revenir avec après
sur ma jambe parce que benjamin veut un
petit peu de temps moi j'aurais demandé
pardon à ma maman que j'adore que
j'adore énormément évidemment comme des
garçons comme leur maman ou les filles
voilà la mission à l'habitat biarritz et
à chaque fois j'ai eu au téléphone elle
me dit que je suis un mauvais fils la
coupe ont très bien puisque je ne
l'appelle
mais voilà je sais que j'ai deux soeurs
elles appellent pratiquement tous les
deux jours et moi je n'appelle jamais
pourtant là avec mon chien avec monde
c'est edgar et voilà et donc je voulais
demander pardon parce que c'est vrai
qu'à chaque fois que je vais au
téléphone je me dis ça y est
à partir de cette fois ci je vais
l'appeler plus souvent j'ai appelé tous
les 2 jours 3 jours et j'ai honte de le
dire mais les semaines passent et je
l'appelle malheureusement peut-être tous
les deux mois et je m'en veux mais même
en voulant je n'arrive pas à passer le
pas je ne suis pas un blocage selon
stefan non maman je t'aime et j'aimerais
bien taper plus haut mais même quand je
t'appelle pas je pense très fort à toi
voilà c'est parce que je t'appelle pas
que je pense pas à toi mais dont on sait
qu'elle a entendu votre message
elle vous regarde nos rares tous les
soirs me dis heureusement que je regarde
la télévision c'est vrai que ton coeur
vivant
j'ai entendu jean michel est ce qu'elle
est au téléphone avec nous commencez
vous n'avez plus de forfaits ont la paix
nous est ce que est ce qu'elle est là
madame madame l'alma d'annemasse et
michel michel michel mas merci d'être
avec nous ce soir au téléphone c'est la
maman de jean michel barraud dites-lui
roddick lui bat maman tu me le dis à
chaque fois tu me sarr proches que tu me
fais régulièrement
voilà donc je te promets et voit la
syrie comptent sur lui pour me le
rappeler de taper beaucoup plus souvent
c'est vrai que je suis une femme je
culpabilise énormément
voilà surtout que j'ai deux soeurs qui
elle tu appelles tout le temps et moi je
vais donc je vais t'appeler beaucoup
plus souvent michel a toujours été
présent tout est réfléchi et puis va
merci à thierry de la tête a pas permis
ainsi échelle vous êtes fier de jean
michel maire ou pas de votre fils oui
oui je vais pas ce oui parce que il me
téléphonait souvent mais il est
tellement gentil que je au début jusqu'à
qui peut passer puis voilà c'est ça se
passe très vite parce que avait été très
très gentil je peux pas lui en vouloir
longtemps voilà ben merci michel proulx
ça fait du bien cette séquence a mais
pardon fait plaisir d'avoir non mais
c'est vrai géraldine manning oui ben moi
aussi je voudrais demander pardon à ma
maman
alors j'espère qu'elle va m'entendre ou
alors elle va lire sur mes lèvres parce
que parce que ma maman et a perdu
l'audition quand j'avais 13 ans et elle
était très jeune elle avait 28 ans et
moi j'étais particulièrement en colère
je trouve ça totalement injuste ce qui
lui est arrivé et comme j'étais ado
rebelle et souvent donc en colère
souvent il m'arrivait de lui parler
derrière son dos ou alors de parler vite
pour qu'elle ne me comprennent pas et je
dois dire que j'en ai eu souvent honte
et donc maman je t'aime tu es
merveilleuse et pardonne moi moi c'est
bon
c'est bon c'est moche tout fait se
ressemblent énormément
isabelle morini-bosc mais voulais
demander pardon à quelqu'un ce soir
c'est assez étonnant
franchement je m'attendais pas du tout à
ça ben oui mais je voudrais demander
pardon à gilles giguère des gilles
verdez il était ici à côté de moi
malgré nos moments de complicité
m'exaspérait mais vraiment souvent parce
que je trouvais excessive parce qu'il
hurlait pas ce qui m'a rendu à moitié
sourde à moitié est complètement dingue
est donc vraiment un moment je me suis
dit mais j'en ai marre quoi mais qui se
tire eh ben depuis qu'il est parti il me
manque vraiment et il me manque vraiment
de plus en plus et me reviennent tous
les moments de grandes complicités et
d'ailleurs j'en profite gilles tu
m'avais promis qu ont dîné ensemble à la
point qu'on fait sept ans que ça se
fasse
alors on vous a préparé une petite amie
viennent beaucoup vous étiez un peu
comme chiens et chats
gillet vous et j'ai une petite surprise
pour voix près hier c'était nul dit le
temps
[Applaudissements]
eh eh bien isa gil est venu que ce soir
et encore ça fait plaisir quand j'ai vu
mon père shia la série nous avons kg
zaoui mais parce que c'est un amour de
mec n'est pas tout ce que je pense mais
je pense que je dis m'a vraiment manqué
gillet vous manqué isabelle hains
beaucoup alors regarde tous les soirs
mais on va pas se mentir ici on dit
toute la vérité
c'est vrai que vous êtes moins présent
on sait les contrer vous allez très vite
revenir nous voir et c'est que dates et
les saccades la taille et donc il est
peu présent cette année
il est chez benjamin le vendredi et bien
sûr vous avez innové onéreux venir nous
voir plaisait semaine c'est juste voilà
je vous le dit on ici voilà ton un peu
ses origines il était là tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps moment gilles est ce qu'on vous
manque alors oui je vous regarde tout le
temps vous manque et beaucoup mais si je
puis vous dire honnêtement c'est
beaucoup mieux sans bras pas mais il ya
beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux sociaux
qui disent que vous voulez en moquez
vous avez un truc à dire examen elle ce
soir mais je l'aimais l'aiment vraiment
je me suis jeté sur elle mais je laime
quoi mais bon c'est toujours dit si
jamais on n'avait pas eu des filles car
ils sont là on moi vous savez ouais là
oui on aurait dit oui mais oui on
regarde et on se touche on s'aime on est
tactile on est on est intellectuellement
proche spirituellement tout aux
physiques mentaux toutefois qu
allez-vous colère c'est bon
isabelle vous auriez pu vous auriez pu
avoir une aventure avec jean ah oui tout
à fait je pense que vous êtes un peu
amoureuse de lui je crois mais voilà
moins à mitis et voilà c'est la
frontière kouame moore arrête dès qu'on
parle ni de politique ni d'histoires
normes et même je vais être un petit peu
amoureuse de lui
vous êtes autant en me montrant beaucoup
c'est vrai oui mais non mais attendez on
peut être amoureux par amitié mais voilà
rémois ya la plana email amoureuse de
moi me amicalement s'est révélée mais
oui bien sûr mais il était mon frère ou
sa soeur oui mais voilà voilà
tout le monde jean-michel voilà un mais
et vous me suis sûr vous allez finir
ensemble
faites vos petits bisous ce week-end si
mais l'autre on va passer une partie du
week end ça va se terminer sa jeunesse
avant ça ça à partir en cacahuète plombé
sa non mais ça je vous le dis ça je le
sais est-ce qu'on peut oui oui je vais
me concentrer parce qu'on peut se
tourner vers benjamin castaldi benjamin
souvent on rigole sur ma vie son mariage
et c'est vrai que j'ai plein de vie on
va on va rappeler votre vie bajra parce
que mine de rien il ya plein de gens et
plein de jeunes gens qui savent pas
vraiment qui vous êtes
benjamin castaldi oui ce n'est pas
seulement ce présentateur du nord vous
avez une famille extrêmement célèbre
faut savoir votre grand père s'était il
monte ans est un des plus grands acteurs
voilà et chanteurs ont vraiment qu'on
ait connu en france c'est un des mecs
les plus célèbres voilà il est du music
hall et même de tous voilà c'est vrai et
votre grand mère simone signoret immense
actrice votre père jean-pierre comédien
jean-pierre castaldi votre maman est
agréé voit la comédienne voilà et c'est
vrai que vous déjà je sais que vous
écrivez un livre sur votre famille vous
allez révéler des secrets de famille non
vote secret a pas de secret je fais des
rêves et des mois mais cannes c'est vrai
que moi j'ai dû me suis je marie
beaucoup de fois et c'est vrai que moi
vous êtes mariée deux fois pour les
belges juste marié quatre fois à chaque
fois hélas assez souvent et c'est vrai
que dans l'hérault dès que j'ai dans ma
vie c'est vrai que j'ai eu trois enfants
3 3 garçons alors on va on va on va
rappeler trois enfants d'abord c'est 3
février julien dont c'est l'anniversaire
ce soir d'ailleurs le grand ben ouais
merci mon dieu nous alors c'est tout
cela même la même femme ancienne c'est
pas la même portée non alors alors
dites-nous bas alors julien pierre
julien et simon c'est avec valérie et
lors de votre première femme oui c'est
avec flavie donc à fait d'accord dont
kenza et c'est vrai que bon et enzo me
suis plutôt beaucoup occupé même si on a
divorcé assez tôt et flavie julien jeu
quand je suis parti il avait trois ans
mais sinon il y avait neuf mois
cette eau et ça donc pardon voilà donc
voulait ce soir si ces comptes sur les
véhicules
non mais c'est vrai parce que je rate
beaucoup de choses maintenant avec l'uja
ce qu'il est à la maison parce que ce
fort ensemble on se parle et c'est super
je te reverrai en fait payer pas l'air
comme ça mais je raisonne voilà pardon
pardon à julien avant six mois
je vous aime voilà c'est tout
pour résumer pour les téléspectateurs
soit vouliez dire pardon à vos enfants
parce que vous trouvez vous n'y étiez
pas s'est présentée j'ai pas été là haut
parce qu'on a c'est notre carrière c'est
quoi c'est la carrière c'est quand on
est amoureux vous est ce que c'est on
est une femme on vit 100 ans on vit ses
astuces et histoire d'amour il ya
forcément des victimes et les victimes
malheureusement c'est souvent les
enfants parce qu'on est on pense à soi
parce qu'on est égoïste on voit là on
vit une histoire d'amour on a envie de
la vivre pleinement
voilà et on n'est pas là moi je suis
parti trois ans en amérique dont il
était très peu eu lui la veille il avait
neuf mois et j'avais une sorte d'amour
avec la vie donc voilà c'est évident
qu'ils ont senti que j'étais pas présent
mais avant ça va mieux je suis content
vraiment je suis très heureux il vit
avec moi le ciment aujourd'hui vous avez
l'impression ce que c'est si on se
connaît bien
j'ai raison qu'aujourd'hui vous en
donner même encore plus voilà je suis
maintenant mais j'ai la chance et j'en
ai deux homos sous mon toit takita jebba
ggn zoé simon et avec les défis d'ordre
enfin j'ai une grande famille qu'est
vraiment recomposée et c'est très
agréable parce qu'effectivement je fais
des choses que j'ai jamais fait dans ma
vie parce que effectivement quand on est
animateur moi j'ai connu le succès à ces
jeunes à 30 ans avec le l'offre où on se
brûle les ailes et on passe à côté d'eux
un moment avec quand vous étiez dans le
nord quand vous étiez dans un succès
incroyable
vous avez un mot vous êtes dit je passe
à côté je vois mes enfants grandir une
robe se dit pas ce qu'il faut c'est que
c'est c'est pas quand on vit c'est après
parce qu'effectivement il ya des
rancoeurs et julien et sinon ils ont été
en colère on le sent un enfant et be
parce que c'est compliqué au début parce
qu'ils ont plein de reproches et qui
savent pas qu'on l'exprimé parce qu'un
enfant il va vous dire des choses dans
le mauvais ordre toujours sur un mot sur
un détail a boosté à la gueule des tas
de choses qui font très mal
donc moi aujourd'hui je suis très
heureux parce que je rattrape beaucoup
de choses avec avec mes trois enfants
avec simon parce que c'est lui que j'ai
le jeu pense le moins vu et c'est vrai
que ce matin et au sport avec lui c'est
génial oui là il a 19 ans on fait plein
de trucs ensemble
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire de
juniors julien hillat il a quinze jours
il a 23 ans 3 23 23 dans m1 julien il
est là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme à gauche je sais que je t'aime mon
chéri qu'est ce que tu as envie de dire
à ton papa ce soir qui est un mec que
j'adore tu le sais regardez comme il est
sensible s'il a déjà une valeur pas ses
yeux quand il pleure pas là non mais
sans rigoler quand il pleure alors là on
y est il a abordé la question voulais
lui dire il a fait ce qu'il a pu
et ça change rien
tu vois c'est ça reste ton père tu fais
il a fait il a fait des choix il a fait
il l'a fait pour lui il les a faits pour
nous aussi parce que j'aimais lui
manquer de rien jusque voilà il le temps
que tu ne rattrape pas mais tu n'y a pas
d'âge pour changer et il l'a fait
aujourd'hui regard dit là il à simon
chez lui moi j'ai commencé un petit peu
ma vie tu vois j'ai quitté le nid est
l'équité le n'y a pas longtemps j'ai
pris mon appartement la lia il ya un an
qu'une caution
[Rires]
je lui en veux de rien il a été il a
quand même été là tant qu'il a pu
et voilà j'ai c'est que je laime tu as
envie de profiter de ton papa
aujourd'hui
ouais j'aimerais beaucoup je peux tu
adressé à lui directv la questura lui
dire aujourd'hui mais je suis fier de
toi il le sait je suis je suis fier
d'avoir le père que j'ai et voilà il n'y
a pas d'âge pour
pour pour changer les choses et
franchement mais c'est l'heure actuelle
voilà c'est un père au top ce rapport au
top vous voulez vous dire pardon ce soir
benji ses premiers trucs qui nous a dit
quand on a dit c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la journée internationale du
pardon et il a dit je veux dire pardon
les enfants est-ce que tu comprends
voilà qui qui qui va vous dire pardon où
tu dis moi pour moi il a été toujours
présent il
voilà je les ai pas ressenti comme lui a
pu le ressentir ce n'est pas d'ailleurs
été présenté aux yeux il n'a pas été il
n'a pas été très présent mais mais
pardon c'était trop facile c'est tu peux
pas on peut pas dire pardon cesser les
regrets mais j'ai pas lui pardonner de
ça et c'est la vie il a vécu sa vie j'ai
manqué de rien peut-être d'un père un
peu plus présent mais voilà lui en veux
pas du tout je lui en veux pas parce que
parce que parce que c'est je pense que
quand on est face à
au choix qu'il a dû à faire face quand
on a la vie qu'il a eu forcément tu as
un moment où voilà il tu dois faire des
choix et il les a faits ça ne fait pas
de moi quelqu'un de malheureux loin de
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un amour mon jute un amour je te fais un
gros bisou bon anniversaire mersiol ses
adversaires du jour un gros cadeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le coffret cadeau time of which he
allait mal tu as envie de payer des
voyages en grèce en ce moment les
voyages en relation un voyage en grèce
bah ouais si injustement je te fais
partie en
a bordeaux
tu pars en grèce aussi c'est pourquoi
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau vous
inquiétez pas ça c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment cadeau
alors si on à christophe oui christophe
est ce que tu as un pardon après valérie
les lignes je sais pas du tout ce que
c'est mais vous avez un pc un autre ça
me fait ça mais ça me fait extrêmement
peur vous c'est quoi votre part ben je
suis pas très à l'aise dans cet exercice
mais voilà c'est l'occasion ou jamais
c'était en fait j'ai une petite soeur
elle s'appelle corinne cas voilà c'était
qu'à échapper une rescapée du carillon
l'attentât après le bataclown 13 nommant
le 13 novembre donc a vraiment failli
mourir et c'est vrai que l'on est
moi j'ai pas eu une enfance facile elle
c'était plus simple on n'avait pas le
même rapport aux repères et c'est vrai
que quand je suis parti après un jeu les
moins vu je m'en suis occupé et j'ai
toujours été assez dur avec elle en fait
parce que voilà moi j'ai la rage est là
- la rage que moi et du coup à chaque
fois je vois l'âge des spu et je vais
peut-être pas dit les mots qu'il fallait
et je vais en profiter la preuve pour
lui dire que je n'aime je sais qu'il
nous regarde là donc voilà donc corinne
je t'aime
gk un autre truc qui est complètement
jaca rien à voir si vous avez dit que
vous regrettiez aussi votre période dans
le x par exonhit est dans l'histoire en
aide à ses vrais du coq à l'âne mais
parce que c'est incroyable
il paraît que vous avez vous regretté
s'étonne vous avez travaillé pour des
films x
zhukov c'est vrai cette histoire on part
j'ai travaillé un an et demi j'ai fait
les relations presse d'une brave vous
écriviez les chats quête des films x
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai la vérité ça y
paraît que vous regrettez oui disons que
c'est un truc dont je mens je m'en vante
pas non plus mais pardon parce que oui
je regrette en rien sa jamais jamais
nous l'eau a tourné dans cette
alimentaire sur des tournages tout ça
mais on va quand même la voûte est dur
de passer ça après ma soeur tremblay
match mais parce que voilà parce que
c'est les deux trucs qu'on avait sur lui
je te jure ça n'a rien à voir
après avoir respecté votre soeur c'est
important valerie plame
oui il paraît que vous avez un os à dire
oui moi je voudrais vous demande vous
demander pardon à vous sert il parce que
on a une relation tous les deux on est
très très proches
je voulais demander pardon oui à vous à
moi oui mais qui soumet les filles je
vais vous expliquer parce que d'abord tu
dis pas je suis conne mais parce qu'on
s'appelle tout le temps oui on vous
connaît énormément de choses l'un sur
l'autre et donc on a des dossiers
évidemment main sur l'autre et moi ce
qui m'arrive depuis huit ans et que un
peu insolente avec vous parce que je
sais des choses et donc je dis des trucs
à l'antenne je vous titille je vous dis
des choses
voilà donc la voudrais vous demander
pardon tenez pas pardon pour un truc que
vous m'avez fait non pour un truc que je
vais vous faire maintenant
je voudrais vous deux attendez donc par
avance aux normes alors ne le fait pas
qui va sortir cette émission celle qui
d'ailleurs je me demande si l'on va pas
rendre l'antenne à dire c'est que voilà
l'embellie attendait parfois je vais
trop loin dans beinheim en faisant tout
depuis le début il dit moi exactement ce
qui se passe quelle est cette histoire
écoutez vous savez qu'on en sait
beaucoup de choses on s'appelle tous les
jours on se parle on connaît nos vies et
c'est donc j'ai des dossiers gdg des
infos j'ai des photos j'ai des filles
mais j'ai des trucs ça voilà j'ai et et
si je suis un peu insolente
oui et donc je vais être encore
insolente une fois de plus je vais vous
demander pardon pour cette insolence
donc qu'est ce que vous avez comme
dossier
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ça savez ce que c'est il faut
une explication expliqué il ya très
longtemps et je crois que c'est un fort
boyard
j'avais fait fort boyard et la nuit je
m'étais mis tout eu à poil et j'avais
déambuler dans le fort la naissance en
voilà mais avec un sac à dos et j'avais
fait pipi duo du fort émotif et donc
jamais réveillé tout le monde voilà tous
les gars et comment vous avez pu vous
procurer votre photo mais écoutez on est
très proches vous et moi et je ne vais
pas pou cave et la personne qui m'a
donné cette photo qui est qui est un
intime et donc c'était bien cette photo
de fort boyard et je ne me trompe pas
exactement
donc c'est quand je me suis bien poilant
de m'excuser d'avoir dévoilé une fois de
plus des choses devant leur public a
besoin savoir il est en toute
transparence et je sais qu'on sait non
mais voit le guen je ne vous pardonne
pas non mais mais mais merci merci quand
même surprenant c'est que vous ayez
cacher le service trois pièces
voilà c'était ça c'est raté c'est ça
c'est ça je ne sais pas moi aussi
j'aimerais demander un pardon ce soir
joli j'aimerais demander pardon
voilà à tous les gens que j'ai pu
blesser parfois voilà c'est vrai que
parfois la chambre des vannes ça y est
une vanne qui peut partir qui peut
partir comme ça qui peut que je pense
pas vraiment je voudrais vous demander
pardon aussi parfois aux personnes de
voile à auchan de ses beats voilà la
régie quand je les bouscule un peu parce
qu'ils font un travail incroyable à tous
les gens qui sont autour
je leur ai demandé pardon aussi au
public parfois parce que quand il est
dans mes émissions voilà ils peuvent
repartir un peu tâche et ce ne sera pas
le cas je voudrais demander pardon aussi
à tous les mecs que j'ai un peu critique
et voilà j'ai été un petit peu loin
parfois donc ce soir c'est vrai que
parfois j'ai trouvé que j'étais un petit
peu dur parfois j'aurais dit oui parce
que vous dites que vous pensez voilà
c'est ça va après parfois on peut le
regretter
oui donc c'est vrai que j'ai pu le
regretter voilà parce que c'est parfois
je suis allé trop loin
voilà j'ai été souvent son fils je
voudrais demander pardon si hammami
parfois parce que c'est un ami voilà
exactement déjà voilà de l'appeler mamie
parce que je sais que lé alep-hama mines
du tout dans sa tête elle est plus à
l'état les jeunes ont fait un bien sûr
voilà mais c'est vrai et je sais que
mamie vous n'aimez pas que je vous
rappel man donc ce soir je vous
appellerai à partir de ce soir je vous
appellerai plus manille mais mais mais
[Musique]
je vais demander pardon à benjamin
castaldi
donc pourquoi de deux parfois m'énerver
pas ce que vous cherchez
parfois je joue je peux vous tapez mais
gentiment gens très bon j'aurais demandé
pardon
quant à christophe carrière parce que ça
fait longtemps que je n'ai pas mis dans
l'émission voilà que je suis très
heureux de le retrouver
voilà pardon je t'avais pas oublié mais
bon voilà doit demander pardon à kelly
aussi parce que parfois je les engueule
c'est vrai parce que voilà comme celle
sa part comme ça pardon à françois view
en fait non pardonne parlons à
jean-michel ma chérie parce que c'est
vrai que parfois c'est vrai que je
t'appelle plus souvent pour les
mauvaises choses que pour les bonnes
mais tu sais que je te trouve excellent
et que tu es vraiment mon ami pour
toujours je ne sais voilà tu sais voilà
je ne demanderai pas pardon beinheim
pardon et eric naulleau de l'avoir
embarqué dans cette galère alors qu'il
était tranquille oui j'espère que tu es
heureux quand même très bon bouder en
bois
arabi a pas de pardon contraindrait
c'est vrai géraldine pardon aussi voilà
de de t'avoir sortie de ton confort
c'est vrai et je vais me demander pardon
surtout pour un truc c'est pour le
chocolat
je
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]